pour ce derby Daniel Sanchez
l'entraîneur tour enjo avait surpris son
monde en titularisant Johan turam dans
les buts et Karim Saidi à la place de
Romain Sartre des changement m à mal par
une entable de match catastrophique du
TFC dès la 2è minute amarabi récupère un
ballon à l'entrée de la surface le
milieu Castel Roussin n'est pas attaqué
et sa demi-volet trompe facilement le
gardien tourangeo un Johann turam pas
très inspiré 4 minutes plus tard sur ce
coup Fran TR aérien Rud Hadad le menur
de jeu berichon double la mise et après
6 minutes de jeu le match semble déjà
terminé au bout de 4 minutes deux
actions de buts voilà c'est l'art de se
mettre vraiment dans la plus mauvaise
des situations donc à partir de là après
tout tout devient beaucoup plus
compliqué puisque chatourau est resté
derrière a balancé des des longs ballons
devant les touronj vont faire preuve
d'orgueil au retour des vestiaires gu
guet se procur une belle occasion sur
cette tête piqué à la 47e minute mais
Vincent Fernandez est bien présent les
Bleus vont rater l'immanquable sur cette
double opportunité à la 52e minute mais
ni titi Buengo ni le jeune ne parvient à
marquer Karim Saidi va même trouver le
poteau sur cette tête lobéa 2 minutes de
la fin mais à force de gâcher le TFC
s'expose en contre et dans les arrêts de
jeu gr crucifie turam pour la troème
fois une bonne seconde mi-temps qui qui
a qui a pas beaucoup de poids après
après après notre entam de jeu voilà
c'est sûr que c'est sûr qu'en estant
mené 2-0 dans un match où voilà c'est
effectivement un derby donc
effectivement il y a il y a l'envie de
partir d'autre quoi qu'il arrive mais
mais on sait qu'on peut marquer des buts
à l'extérieur mais maintenant s'il faut
s'il faut toujours marquer un but de
plus que l'adversaire mettre trois buts
tout le temps pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
gagner c'est ça ne met pas dans de dans
de bonnes dispositions après deux
lourdes défaites à l'extérieur Arin il y
a de semaines et vendredi dans le derby
du centre les supporters tour Enjou
peuvent craindre pour le prochain match
de bleu qui aura lieu à Boulogne en cas
de défaite dans 5 jours le TFC aura
peut-être dit définitivement adieu à la
Ligue 1